genesis 1 says man was created first
you're misinterpreting ah
here we are in the third day of creation
in chapter one chapter two it says the
opposite
so for example the question i need to
ask is were the plants created first and
then the mankind
or was mankind created first and then
prance
check out our sponsors nature's blends
they specialize in premium ethiopian
black seed products
the website is in the description link
below you can also use the discount code
salam 10 for 10 of their products
so for example you know in genesis 1
verse 12
it says that man was created after the
plants and in genesis chapter 2 verse 5
9 says man was created before the plans
so that's
a clear contradiction like was it was
okay go to
the book of genesis genesis 1 12
112
[Music]
man and then if you go to the book of
genesis 2
verse 5 9 man was created before the
plants
no that's that's not what it says it
says that the the herbs of the field did
not yet grow
i.e on the on the third on the third day
of creation
when the plants were created the seeds
were put down but they hadn't gone yet
okay one second so in first generation
it says
that god created man before the plant it
doesn't say those words
okay what's it say
for the lord god had not caused it to
rain upon the earth
there was not a man until the ground
okay so there was no men
man there was no man to till the ground
so before man
before man was created the plants could
not go
because the uh because there was nobody
to uh
to tend the land okay so god first put
the plant seeds in the seeds then yes
and once man was created then
um then then god put this uh that then
then god caused it to rain and man till
the ground and under her
can you go to genesis chapter two verse
five to nine
yes can you read that so i just read
verse five for you
i'll read verse six now no no that was
genesis one wasn't that just
um and the earth brought forth grass
her building seed after its kind and
tree yielding fruit
whose seed was in itself after its kind
and god saw that it was good
do you like it here i'm trying to find
oh is it in english
yeah i've got an english on one side
okay one second
these are the verses yeah yeah okay
and the earth brought forth grass herb
yielding seed after his
kind and tree yielding fruit whose seed
was in itself after its kind
and god saw that it was good and there
was eve and there was evening and there
was morning and third day
and god said let there be light in the
forming of heavens to divide the day
from the night and let there be four
let there be four signs and four seasons
and four days and four years
let them be for lights in the firmament
of heaven to give light upon the earth
and it was so and god made two great
lights the greater light to rule the day
and the lesser light to rule the night
and the stars also and god set them in
the firm in heaven to give light upon
the earth
and god saw that it was good and god
slept let that let us
make mankind in our own image so in the
26th verse
after he's talking about the creation of
the plants then
it's saying it created mankind yes
in genesis chapter
genesis chapter 2 it says the opposite
so for example the question i need to
ask is were the plants created first and
then the mankind
or was mankind created first and then
prance
what it says in chapter one is that
is that god created these uh god created
this vegetation
it doesn't say that it's sprouted it
doesn't say that it had grown
whereas in chapter two now it says it's
growing and sprouting
that's it only goes and sprouts after
man tills the land
before that it does not that's that's
fine that's fine i agree with you i
agree with you that you need mankind
to carry that out but here is talking
about creation it's not talking about
if if man was there to give rise to it
it's saying that god created the plants
first and then in another part it
contradicts itself it's like
if allah says in the quran this is why
allah says if this book was not from
other than your lord you would find
contradictions and errors in it
and it's an open challenge to the people
of the book that bring
a chapter like you or find
contradictions and errors in it so god
almighty if
allah said we created uh the
elephant first there's no verse what i'm
saying we created elephant first
and then we created the man mankind and
another verse it says we created mankind
first
and then we created elephant that's a
contradiction so how do you reconcile
with that very contradiction because it
says it created the prance first
then it says mankind and then in genesis
chapter 2 it says
no it was mankind we created first and
then it was a plant
ah here we are in the third day of
creation in chapter one
it does it talks about it talks about
herbie it says it brought forth grass
herb yielding seed after its kind and
tree yielding fruit
but in chapter two it doesn't it talks
about
it talks about herb of the field it
talks about
it talks about plant of the field and
herb of the field
those are not definite necessarily the
same thing
grass herb building seed and shielding
seed
and it says after it says whose seed was
in itself
so the seed was inside the thing
and only afterwards did they come out
you know still the problem is was
mankind created before the plant
or were the plants created before the
man plants were created first
genesis man was created then that then
the
then got then god brought to rain then
man till the earth
and then the plants grew but genesis 1
says ground route
genesis once says man was created first
yes no it doesn't say man was created
before the plants were created
it says it says that man was a man was
created
before the plants had sprouted
sprouting and creating the same thing
what i want to know is even
before we sprout i'm talking about were
i'm not talking about plants coming out
yeah okay i'm talking about
which one did god create first man or
the plants or the seeds what everyone
got the seed
or the man mankind which one was first
because once his man kind of once said
uh the plants once his plants one says
mankind
you're misinterpreting and hold on a
second
it's my father yeah you have to answer
father is very important